make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and the loki tv show is
coming out soon so i thought we would
cover
a bunch of loki's stuff it'd be kind of
cool uh we're actually going to try to
coincide this
so that we end up getting to the well we
end up getting to a really cool story by
the time the tv show launches because i
feel like the show is going to give us a
bunch of different versions of loki so
be aware
that we are going to be explaining all
those different versions of loki or
different characters and things like
that like we did with wand division and
falcon in the winter soldier we're going
to be doing that during loki
but uh what we're also going to do here
is we had previously covered part of
this so like what we're doing with the
x-men for example
playing a bit of ketchup here so what
we're actually gonna do is combine
videos right so we're gonna take
uh the return of thor video loki
becoming a woman we're gonna combine it
into this one and then
upload it all as thor volume one because
technically it is
okay so it's like 1 15 in the morning
right now and i
am totally wired and i guess it's just
because i've been working out all the
time so i have like energy
all the time like i can't sleep i feel
like i'm gonna go upstairs and lay down
after i record this and just crash out
for like 10 hours which kind of sucks
anyway i want to be a little bit
interesting here i want to try my hand
at recording or at least covering the
beginning of j michael cerzinski's run
on thor we're going to cover this first
issue as a separate video because
there's a lot to explain
and also kind of a test thing right if
you guys dig it we'll probably just go
ahead and cover each individual issue
over the course of the week or over the
course of however long it takes us to
get through all 12 so 12 days but for
those of you guys who are who got into
like jason aaron's thorpe uh which is to
say like thor got a thunder with like
gore the god butcher and all that kind
of stuff those of you guys who are
reading thor right now and the idea that
like you had the events of siege on
asgard and so on and so forth all that
starts
here right like this all starts with j
michael strzinski's run and this all
comes off the tales of ragnarok right we
talked about that story before and in
fact we covered it uh you'll find the
whole thor playlist down in the
description but the idea behind ragnarok
was to basically remove thor from the
landscape and one of the things a lot of
people don't know if you go back and you
read the old interviews from from casada
and all them the idea was to actually
kill off thor and to remove him from the
landscape for a while uh ultimately they
didn't
dream uncles strazinski brought him back
a few years later with
really with this story uh but the idea
here was to basically bring thor back in
a way that would kind of return his
character back to his roots right that
fell in line with what it is that editor
and
editor-in-chief joe casada wanted to do
right like take all the characters and
put them back to the way they used to be
spider-man goes back to being single the
avengers go back to being the the
kind of classic mainstays of marvel sort
of uh coming together on a single team
hence the reason why we got the new
avengers by brian michael bendis the
x-men their entire population was
reduced down to 198 so it was a
wholesale reshuffling of marvel across
the board
and thor was no exception and so what
this does is it initially sort of picks
up
seemingly with thor kind of recounting
his life right the things that he's
known the successes he's had
fighting alongside the warriors three
ultimately becoming donald blake falling
in love with sif and then going on and
eventually falling in love with jane
foster only to lose jane foster
different things along those lines but
it's basically kind of you know going
over his life and and the struggles he's
dealt with the fact that he basically
faced off against these various forces
during ragnarok died
it's just kind of a solid run over right
it's it's a way for j michael suginski
to say hey guys here's what's going on
with thor but regards to the story
what's going on with thor is that he's
not really alive but he's not really
dead he's in what's called the void now
in my mind the way i looked at this was
that under normal circumstances
thor would have died right like he would
have gone to where hello was right he
would have gone to that like
afterlife more or less well he probably
would have gone to valhalla to be honest
because of the fact that he was such an
honorable warrior that kind of a thing
it looked like and and from what i
recall i think sherzinski had an old
forum post that he made where he was
talking about this and he said the idea
was that the reason why thor didn't go
there
is because of the fact that donald blake
anchored him to life right because when
it comes to the donald blake thor
relationship and i want to talk about
this because i feel like this is
something that really confuses a lot of
people and now's as good of a time as
any to really bring this up
this whole idea here with with donald
blake basically having this conversation
with
thor as as donald blake's literally
going about and just kind of talking
about things heading towards his
destination grabbing thor's hammer
different things like that
what he does is he basically says we're
the same person and and the reason why
you see thor saying things like well
there was an odin spell that split us
apart and and like that doesn't it
doesn't work like that anymore is
because when you go back and you read
the old thor stories when he first
appeared back in 1962 right so the old
journey into mystery stories what you
got was was essentially
a byproduct of the time right which is
to say ever since action comics issue
number one in 1938 and the introduction
of superman as the first superhero
alter egos had been a thing of comic
books right they were a mainstay they
were a staple the concept of an alter
ego was tried and true something that
you didn't really mess with too much
and so we got that with thor right you
go back and you read the old stories you
had this guy named donald blake and
donald blake was this this doctor who
had kind of a limp of sorts he had
a handicap and he was hanging out with
jane foster who he was in love with and
she didn't really return his affection
and there was like this weird alien
invasion thing kind of going on so he
runs and he hides in a cave and he ends
up
ends up finding a stick and he gets
frustrated he smacks the stick on a rock
and the stick turns into mjolnir and he
turns into thor
with with the old stanley and jack kirby
comics the way those were written
it was not thor who was turning into
donald blake and the other way around
it was basically this idea that like
donald blake was channeling the power of
thor right so like he was possessing
thor's power and looking like thor
that's the way it was originally done
all this
changed in the thought in thor issue
number 159 and what marvel did is they
basically came out and said by virtue of
uh jack kirby's tales of asgard stories
and and stanley writing the writing the
thor stories is what they said was
at some point in the past thor was an
actual deity right he's an actual being
that existed out there but was full of
hubris he was full of arrogance and so
because of that odin wanted to teach
thor humility
and then in turn he basically created or
crafted the persona of donald blake
literally fabricated this guy out of
nowhere and then wiped all of thor's
memories and knowledge of who he was
and then stuck his essence inside of
donald blake and so as a result of that
donald blake went forward believing that
he basically
lived his entire life and that he was
channeling the power of thor
and so following that the two characters
were aware of the others like actual
purpose where they came from that kind
of thing but all that changed again when
walt simonson took over thor with issue
number 337 now technically
walt simonsen was drawing thor with
issue 260 right he drew issues 260 to
271 but he took over his rider with
issue number 337
and with donald blake he snipped that up
quick fast and in a hurry and so what
ended up happening
is in in uh the introduction of beta ray
bill in that comic that what odin did is
he actually removed the enchantment of
donald blake right he basically said
that like thor and donald blake are no
longer the same person that this kind of
you know magical essence that's being
crafted out of nowhere this donald blake
persona is gonna be
pulled away from thor and it's gonna be
stuck inside of beta rayville's hammer
stormbreaker so that walt simon can
use it in the future if you wanted to or
anybody else could and so as a result of
that from that point going forward
thor was no longer associated with
donald blake they had nothing to do with
each other and thor was
always just thor and it ran like that
for decades right it ran like that for
years and years and years
right up until now and this is why jay
michael cerzinski's run is so important
is because it fell in line with a
charter of what it is that joe casada
wanted to do
set everything back to right so
everything to the way that it was
supposed to be i would just
say setting characters back to the old
school line of thinking and so that's
why these two guys are having this
conversation is because the essence of
donald blake is
reinstated right it's basically back
here again donald blake is his own being
out there somewhere and he basically
anchors thor to the real world right so
like it's still like a singular physical
body
but it's basically the essence of thor
the mind of thor his spiritual
existence more or less sitting in this
void and donald lake is housing the
physical body right so like what will
happen is eventually they'll switch and
that's exactly what takes place this
whole conversation that goes on here is
donald blake basically telling
telling thor you have to come back
because if you don't the world will fall
to ruin now in terms of how it is that
donald blake knows this donald blake
doesn't he's really kind of ambiguous
here right and that was sort of j
michael jordanski saying hey look thor
just has to come back and for the most
part like it was sort of hand wavy it
didn't really get offer a whole lot in
the way of an explanation and fans
didn't really care right zozinski knew
that
for the most part fans weren't really
gonna care how it is that donald blake
knew these things all fans really wanted
was for thor to come back and this was
as good of a reason as annie to
basically bring him back here right and
so as a result of that where literally
thor says like i don't want to return
because i've seen what happens in this
life that i live i'm part of the cycle
of ragnarok right for those of you guys
who aren't familiar with that ragnarok
is the
the end times of asgard right the
destruction of asgard the difference
here
is that where ragnarok is essentially
like the end of all things for all the
asgardian beings what marvel ended up
doing was basically giving us this
scenario whereby
all the asgardians since the very
beginning of all things in existence all
asgardians have repeatedly died and been
reborn
as part of the cycle of ragnarok
seemingly an unlimited number of times
and in fact marvel actually came back
and they modified thor issue number 159
which gave us the reason why it was that
thor was banished to earth as donald
blake and actually tacked onto that and
said that odin did that one of course to
teach thor humility but two in order to
escape the cycle of ragnarok it was the
one thing that odin had never done
before he'd never cast thor down to
earth the cycle of ragnarok had always
gone through the process of thor staying
on asgard and then everything comes to
an end and then everything's reborn
again and so on and so forth and so as a
result of that donald blake's response
is yeah man but like that's the nature
of things right it's who you are like
you you're a hero you're a savior like
yes you're going to lose people over the
course of your life but it doesn't take
away from the
the achievements that you've made it
doesn't take away from like the great
things that you've done you have to
return to earth because if you don't
then ultimately the planet is going to
fall to ruin and so as a result of that
where thor is sort of fighting against
these various beings and various demons
that try to keep him there
in the end he ends up summoning his
hammer right it ends up summoning
mjolnir to himself being more or less
reborn
as as thor and so what this does is it
kind of goes forward from here right and
so essentially what this does is kind of
give us the way
thor always was right i mean you never
really saw it this way if you look at
the old stanley and jack kirby comics
but this is basically how it was it's
almost like a bruce spanner incredible
hulk dichotomy and so far that donald
blake is currently housing the physical
form the physical body of both thor
and donald blake he's walking around
when the the stick gets hit on the
ground or whatever it is and and thor's
activated they switch places right like
thor's physical essence goes into the
body he becomes donald blake
donald blake actually goes to the void
and they they kind of go back and forth
as they need to but of course this leads
to to donald lake taking up residence in
brockton oklahoma now the reason why he
chose rocks in oklahoma is because
that's where the hammer lands but it's
also the place where ultimately
thor is going to start start making his
move and building everything up right
and so the cool thing about this is that
what it does is it has donald blake
renting a hotel room donald blake going
upstairs into his room and really for
the first time since the events of
ragnarok and really for the first time
in decades which is
a pretty big deal for a lot of thor fans
donald blake takes a stick
smacks it on the ground and thor returns
in his reborn form it's really cool for
people who have been like a fan of thor
for a very long time or who have been
reading for a really really long time it
was a great return it was a great
reprieve and again that's what kasada
and strzok were looking for they were
looking for this idea of bringing thor
back in a way to where it could kind of
reinvigorate interest right it could be
like old school thor as you remember him
him and donald blake that kind of a
thing
okay so for those of you guys who were
following our videos on uh early start
our first video on j michael
sterzinski's thor i haven't forgotten
about you guys it's just been super
super busy but we are picking this up
and in this video loki becomes a chick
loki becomes a woman now in the last
video we basically ended with
thor essentially recreating asgard in
brockton oklahoma
in this part of the video we actually
moved forward to a video that we
actually did a rundown on like we did a
rundown on iron man vs
thor and that was really really fun
right that was a really fun one to do
but in order to keep it in continuity
with where i guess keep it in line with
how we're doing these videos we're gonna
kind of run over this again not super
hardcore but we're gonna run over this
again because this takes place after the
events of civil war now remember during
the whole events of civil war like we
were looking at that we were kind of
hoping the good guys would win they
didn't the bad guys
well i guess what passes for the bad
guys one superhuman registration ran uh
won out right now there were a few
things that came
out of civil war that even after civil
war we didn't cover like we didn't cover
the mighty avengers which came after
civil war that was basically the
avengers team that served as kind of an
antithesis to the secret avengers right
but the way that played out is you
basically had carol danvers leading an
avengers team they kind of operated as a
long arm
of of superhuman registration right like
if you if you weren't registered and you
were running around doing things
like carol danvers avengers team would
catch up to you eventually mighty
avengers was rebranded and re-christened
and essentially became luke cage's
mighty avengers which included adam
beshear the blue marvel which was really
really good it was a really good run
but this takes place almost immediately
after right so iron man is now the
director of shield superhuman
registration is in effect and
superheroes cannot operate within the
united states unless they register
themselves with shield and the federal
government the problem with this is that
this is thor right so thor just does
what he wants to
and that's just the way it is and it's
hilarious because you know when he gets
to new orleans
of course this is post hurricane katrina
so new orleans is in a lot of ways
devastated
getting in here remember thor is on the
hunt for asgardians but thor doesn't
know explicitly what the asgardians look
like right like all he knows by virtue
of what it was that donald blake told
him
is that the asgardians aren't truly dead
right like their spiritual essences have
basically lived on
and recreated and like created human
forms right like there's beings that are
out there where they're speaking their
spirits have gone
into those individuals and it's up to
thor to find them and so what he ends up
doing is tracking down this guy who's
out in
out in new orleans you know and it's
like hey look like i know who you truly
are even though you don't know and this
guy's kind of like well whatever man
he doesn't know who thor is and that's
going to be the common theme when it
comes to thor rescuing these various
asgardians is they're not going to know
who he is right they don't even know who
they are they're just kind of
being their their s their spiritual
essence is kind of hidden and locked
away inside these various individuals
the problem with this is that where thor
tries to talk reason into the sky
suddenly he's met by the arrival of iron
man and let me tell you something thor
is pissed like thor was already in in
like a really pissy mood iron man makes
it worse because what he does is show up
here
this is one of the things i love the
most about the right now we did that
episode right like like iron man showed
up here and like
he's he's he's tough right like he's the
big guy right like he's the director of
shield
he's like the big dude on the block iron
man's like dude you have to work within
the system you have to register and thor
just
calls down the thunder and immediately
like gets to work like he starts going
to work on iron man and the reason why
is is those you guys who never saw the
rundown video and who never saw my
videos on
civil war during that event what you
ended up learning is that at some point
in the past iron man reed richards these
guys really more iron man than anybody
else had taken a piece of thor's hair
so that if thor ended up perishing they
could copy him they could clone him they
could make a new version of him and they
did that right the character's name was
ragnarok which is kind of stupid but
they ended up basically making like a
robot version of thor which
went awry and actually killed a
superhero named goliath who was
previously one of the individuals who
used pym particles to become a superhero
and so as a result of that
you've basically got like thor sitting
here saying okay so like let me see if i
understand this man so basically i died
or at least i was believed to have died
you know and
in order to to honor my memory you make
a robot out of me which in turn
kills one of our superheroes and then
you show up here on on you know running
up on me
telling me that i've got to follow your
rules he's like no man like you're a
human dude i'm a god man so like
like i don't follow your rules you
follow mine and it's just it's amazing
because he immediately goes to work on
tony stark it's not even a contest right
like it's not even like tony stark's
putting up a good fight he's standing a
great chance
no no no tony stark is getting decimated
like it's one of the coolest things
right like this is
one of the reasons why i love j michael
strozinski's writing he was so good at
this because he would be like hey guys
i'm going to show you a fight and i'm
going to show you a fight that's won
quite readily and in no uncertain terms
and it's going to be awesome and that's
literally what happens here right like
iron man chooses repulsor beams thor
hits it away
i mean there's there's nothing that iron
man can really do here the response here
of thor is here is how things are going
to work right
it's not even saying like let's come to
an agreement it's no no like i'm going
to tell you how it's going to work and
then you're going to accept it and
you're going to go
forward with it or you're going to die
and it's basically like i rebuilt asgard
in brockton oklahoma and there it will
stay i am on a mission to find my
asgardians and when i do
they will travel to brockton oklahoma
and they will reside in asgard
that's how it's going to be like your
affairs your your whole thing with your
your laws of men and all that kind of
stuff doesn't apply to us
because at any given point we could just
say the heck with it and raise this
world to the ground so either you can do
what we tell you to do or you can perish
it could be easy or it could be hard man
and so as a result of that
iron man's just kind of like yeah dude
good talk and he basically leaves right
he basically leaves and he ends up
traveling back to his base of operations
you go back to back to shield and
everything
looking at how how readily his armor was
destroyed by thor and when the question
is asked well what do we do like are we
going to do anything about broxton or
the response of iron man is no we're not
we're going to leave it there and the
reason why is because they're playing a
dangerous game right like what we end up
learning
is this guy that thor was trying to get
his hands on that he's been talking to
once he reasons with this guy and once
he says hey look i get you don't want to
leave these people behind but you have a
higher duty here and you have to recall
what that higher duty is and so the
results of that is this guy basically
says okay
and then he basically allows thor to
bring that essence out and we end up
finding
that this guy is heimdall right now this
is the reason why thor
went for him is because heimdall is
all-seeing he can see
everything out there and so in response
to that what this means is that with
heimdall on the side of thor and iron
man basically
saying hey look i don't know exactly
that's if that's what's going on but i
do know that things are kind of popping
off here they'd be picking a fight with
gods
the avengers would be foolish if they
decided to go to war with asgard you
would need some big heavy hitters
fighting on the side of the avengers in
order to be able to win but the chances
those guys actually working for them are
slim because iron man's pissed everybody
off so like no one's going to really
side with him if iron man shows up to
like the super 2 to all the superheroes
who have gone underground with his hat
in his hand and saying hey guys so like
i kind of screwed up and i need your
all's help to basically survive against
asgard they're going to be like sorry
about your luck you know and they're
gonna send them packing
and that's basically gonna be it and so
as a result of that what you end up
getting
is thor jumping from one location to the
next traveling to various locations he
ends up traveling to africa basically
dealing with these freedom fighters
and the freedom fighters are being led
by what's basically the warriors three
it's a cool thing to see thor moving
from one location to the next and
basically waking up these various
asgardians and then gathering together
and having them returning to
their previous form now the cool thing
is he doesn't just he doesn't just like
bail out right so like in the instance
of of these african freedom fighters
it's not as though he shows up here and
he's like excuse me everybody everybody
saw what you're doing i gotta wake up my
asgardian friends and he wakes them up
and it's like okay guys everybody back
to it gotta go and then he basically
leaves he stays in in fights right these
days and helps and that's one of the
important things to bear in mind when it
comes to thor is at the moment
the the priority in what thor is doing
is waking up the asgardians and bringing
them back right but it's not like he's
gonna leave a country of innocent people
to die and just be like that's just kind
of the way it goes man it's business as
usual and call it a day the cool thing
about this is that once the warriors
three are restored knowing notice this
thor's going with the people he trusts
the most right he trusts heimdall more
than anybody else because heimdall
really has no reason to lie
heimdall's loyalty is absolute loyalty
is to the protection of asgard it's the
role he serves right and not only that
of course he's got the all-seeing eye so
basically he can tell thor where to go
and who to look for
but at the same time bringing in the
warriors three are his most trusted
battle his most trusted companions when
it comes to to engaging in conflict and
so what ends up happening here
is heimdall basically points thor in the
direction of a place where various
individuals are being kept
being kept in prison this place is kind
of hidden this place is locked off
nobody's really supposed to know but he
basically says a huge
number of our group of us as guardians
are being held here in this location
by a foe that i can't tell you about
you're basically going to have to go and
you're going to have to face this foe on
your own and do the best you can when he
gets in there when he basically starts
when he ends up discovering what this
foe is
it's the destroyer armor the destroyer's
got a long history when it comes to
asgard right the destroyer armor was
originally created by the sky fathers
but mostly odin in order to basically
defeat the celestials or at least to
challenge the celestials but the
destroyer armor is an insanely powerful
piece of
technology right like an insanely
powerful being and so thor facing off
against the destroyer really takes all
he has and it's cool to see that because
when that happens and when the destroyer
armor is is ultimately defeated by thor
the destroyer armor cracks open
and out falls balder to the brave and
this is cool because if you go and you
look at norwegian mythos like the actual
asgard
uh i guess really the real mythos of
asgardian here in the real world the
fates had decried that if bald of the
brave were to die
then it would signal the starting of
ragnarok and that's one of the reasons
why baltimore the brave was bathed
bathed in waters where he was basically
immortal the only thing that that was
missing was a single section of him in
marvel comics
ball of the brave is similar in that
regard but if he dies it doesn't mean
ragnarok is going to happen the cycle of
ragnarok the way the prophecies were
laid out is that loki was the one who
was going to kick off ragnarok and so it
really it really ties somewhat into the
real world mythos insofar as baldr is a
character who basically met like it was
always like if he dies something bad
will happen that was really kind of
the gist of it right it was the idea
that if balder died the cycle of
ragnarok would start it wasn't until you
started getting into the years leading
up to thor disassembled in the ragnarok
story that it was like baller doesn't
really have anything to do with it at
all he can die and it'll suck but it's
not going to start ragnarok it was
basically
loki will start ragnarok he's the source
of it all and so as a result of that
baldr basically speaks to thor and says
like the idea here was that
i had always existed in such a way to
where it was my job to protect asgard
right like if i fell asgard would fall
as well and the problem with this is
that when i felt i had failed in my
mission i failed to protect asgard and
so as a result of that i didn't really
know
what to do like it was an internal
conflict in myself between accepting the
fact that asgard had fallen there was
nothing i could have done about it and
the fact that i failed and so as a
result of that
what it basically did is it led to him
basically being thrown inside the
destroyer armor and then gathering all
of his people together and it really led
to him imprisoning them
but regardless of the circumstance with
balder being freed of course baldr is
basically sent back to asgard and so
what is up happening is thor gets in
here and he's grabbing the last of the
people who are there
and he ends up coming up coming upon a
woman who he believes to be sith
and as he starts talking as he says you
know turn around my love you know it's
good to see you again my my beautiful
woman my beautiful dear the love of my
life she turns around
hello my love and it's loki
loki becomes a chick look he's a girl
but loki being a woman is is amazing
because what he basically did was steal
the body of sif
he stole the body that was meant for sip
now here's the funny thing is loki
kind of parades around and really
presents himself to thor in such a way
where he's basically harmless now
because what he says is like my entire
existence leading up to the events of
ragnarok was to cause ragnarok right
like everything i did was for the
purpose of causing ragnarok of getting
to a point where ragnarok would
basically be initiated by me but that
was the sole purpose that i had that's
all that i was really supposed to do and
now that i've done that
there's no reason for me to be a bad guy
anymore i'm basically starting over i'm
starting from scratch like i'm doing
things all over again i'm basically a
good guy now now
thor extends a bit of an olive branch
but the olive branch is on a pretty
short leash right i mean thor's not like
well okay brother i trust you man like
it's awesome to see you again bud it's
cool to see here because what we end up
learning
this is this is this is one of the
reasons why i love the character of loki
so much what we end up learning is that
none of this is what it appears
because what loki does is start
communicating he starts communicating
with somebody who we can't see
and loki basically starts saying that
thor is a bit of a goof
thor trusts people implicitly trust his
asgardians implicitly which is not the
worst thing in the world but there are
asgardians out there who want to see him
fall and so as a result of that what
thor will do
is thor will basically lie and wait and
thor will start releasing different
people
uh based on those he can trust the most
of those he can trust the least but
what's what's going on here is loki
saying we can basically have our chance
you and i working together as those
individuals are released as thor begins
to release those individuals whom he
trusts and whom will operate under the
guise of i'm here to fulfill my purpose
and i don't really have any ill will
against you thor
they will lie in wait and what they'll
be waiting for is somebody to help them
make a move somebody who can help them
achieve their goal without fear of being
totally obliterated by thor whatever
that goal happens to be
most likely the fall of thor and so with
this individual who loki's speaking to
if you know he's basically saying if we
work together we can work alongside
those individuals who want to see thor
fall
and we can bring ruin to thor we can
bring him down and then we can we can
basically
plunder asgard like we could seize
control of that entire place and the
person you end up finding out loki is
talking to
is none other than probably the greatest
villain in all of marvel comics
victor von doom allah doctordoom
so continuing on with this uh basically
with with asgard being rebuilt in
brockton oklahoma
that people in broxton are experiencing
what it's like to live with us guardians
[Laughter]
like they're all they've all basically
become daryl from that little thor short
you guys remember that from back in the
day when thor had like his roommate
daryl
um it's really this is really one of
those it's really more of a fun story
right in the sense that one of the first
things that happens is you basically
pick up with hogan now hogan is one of
the warriors three
and the idea behind this is he actually
traveled from oklahoma to texas
something like over 100 miles to knock
out a couple of boars and then bring
them back to asgard so that people can
kind of feast on them right just part of
the offerings for the dinner and he
actually helped out a couple of guys or
really just this kid named
named steve who's basically trying to
change a tire and it's one of these
instances where they just kind of have
an encounter with with one of the
asgardians and so it's kind of a cool
thing because a lot of these guys are
kind of curious about them they're
enamored by them i mean
it is a pretty strange situation that in
the aftermath of the destruction of
asgard when loki basically led a revolt
and led to most of the asgardians being
killed and then himself was killed by
thor when thor destroyed the world tree
that that with you know asgard just kind
of being rebuilt
in brockton people just kind of like
this is a little strange uh it's
interesting but it's strange
and so they actually end up offering him
a ride back home and he's like no he's
like i prefer the walk
i want to be the first asgardian with a
tan and that's one of the things that's
going on is a lot of these guys are kind
of changing
kind of offering different stories here
right they're sort of uh giving
different accounts of their experiences
coming across different asgardians and
and it's kind of intriguing because all
this is actually being watched by thor
and we'll talk about why here in a
second but the next thing you do is you
switch over to a guy by the name of bill
now bill was kind of walking down the
street one night when he was met by the
arrival
of kelda now anybody who read j michael
cerzinski's run on
thor knows that the story of kelda and
bill is like this beautiful story
but it is stupidly tragic at the same
time it's it's so
sad but it's amazing so bill is like
like i i love the way the bill's done
here right so this chick she's like
she's like i'm kelda right like i was
born of the light in the sky
and and sunrises and the wind and who
are you and he's like i'm bill
born of bills my grandfather was big
bill and my dad was little bill and me
i'm bill jr i mean he's he's just
i wouldn't say he's simple but he's just
like he's he's just so homegrown right
there's just there's something about a
person like that
that just kind of gives off this air of
just non-extravagance right and they're
just
a cool person like you know what i mean
it's kind of hard to describe right but
they're just like
a cool person and the result of this is
that she really kind of picks up on that
and she's like well bill is a fine man
right bill's short for william
you know i knew of william the third he
was a king right he was he was sovereign
of his people he was a great and
honorable man
you should be proud of the name that you
wear and he's like yes ma'am and she's
like huh
man so ultimately and this this is this
is this is this is cool i love the way
this is done right
the way this plays out is that she's
like okay well it's about time for me to
go he's like hold on i have a question
for you she's like okay he's like what's
it like living up there
in asgard right like living up there
among all those those gods those
asgardian people and the response she
gives is intriguing she's like you know
it's kind of funny that you ask that
because oftentimes we ask ourselves
what's it like living down there where
you are and she's not really saying it
in like a disparaging way right like
what's it like being part of the lower
caste in society that's not really what
she means it's just
you know it's one of these things where
it's kind of an overlooked concept that
as asgardians are as
intrigued by humanity as humanity is
intrigued by the asgardians now remember
because the third host of the celestials
the asgardians cannot interfere in the
affairs of mortal men otherwise the
celestials will come back and destroy
them all and so they kind of have to
watch from afar now one of the big
differences between kelda and the other
asgardians is a lot of the other
asgardians are content staying in
asgard and looking on humanity some of
whom look down their nose at humanity
where they see them as feeble they see
them as weak
not really worth in their their notice
or their time or energy but kelda is
intrigued by them specifically she's
intrigued by bill
right because in her time in asgard and
even just kind of wandering around
bill seemed like a pretty basic guy and
she was curious what it's like to live
his life and so ultimately uh you know
she's like well i mean you know since
since i even doles my curiosity here
perhaps you'll do the same
and come one night to satisfy your
interests kelda wants the d
and it's like bill man you better make
good on that promise dude
she literally left the door open for you
gentlemen as frustrating as it is and as
much as we would prefer women just
tell us what they're thinking instead
it's really more of just like games
right it's like mind games things like
that
so if you wanna if you you wanna if you
wanna date man you gotta you gotta learn
to play the game as frustrating as it
can be sometimes you got to learn to
play the game
and so it's cool right it's a cool
little thing because bill's like all
right but
the whole situation all these different
stories that are being told by these
people in broxton are all being
overlooked by thor and his donald blake
persona right in his human persona
because one of the important things to
know here is i wouldn't say that the
people of broxton
having a disdain for the asgardians
being there would be enough for thor to
want to leave
but it is it's one of these things where
he is curious about how all this
unfolds right it is curious about how
people view the asgardians because one
of the things to know
is that the the ability for the
asgardians to stay here and to
experience what would more or less be a
peaceful life
is largely contingent on the citizens of
broxton and we'd actually we'll actually
see that unfold later on
when the citizens of roxane actually end
up turning against the asgardians which
there's a pretty cool reason for that
it's actually an event called siege on
asgard
uh but it's amazing right it's a really
really good story but one of the things
that happens here
is thor is like okay the biggest issue
is it's kind of coming out of the
previous discussions that we had where
we talked about how thor was traveling
around
and freeing the different asgardians
from their mortal prisons more or less
when they had all died and their
essences were reborn
in mortal bodies instead of going from
like one place to the next which is
lengthy and exhausting instead thor uses
a full brunt of his energy
to literally activate all of them across
the world right to basically
wake up every single asgardian across
the entire planet and they all come
colin right every single asgardian is
activated brazil
in in los angeles the whole nine yards
it's kind of an intriguing thing
because with this overwhelming thor and
really almost thor kind of being knocked
out
and entering into what is more or less
his ver his version
of the of the odin's sleep it leaves
asgard largely wide open and unprotected
and this is a pretty dangerous situation
since we already know that loki is
working alongside
dr doom but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you